how far into the future is this
woman and her associated works going to
keep coming on my radar
oh yeah that tracks
[Music]
i've been on record in the past as
saying i don't intend to talk about
harry potter
in the future however i've perjured
myself on that a little bit before in
that
jk rowling has come up again in topics
that i felt the need to discuss
and in this case i'm perjuring myself
ever so slightly
i should probably clarify my position on
that i will not
ever be simply reviewing
a piece of harry potter associated
anything not the future movies not
this game which i'll be talking about
and let's also be clear i'm never going
to buy this game
and not just for the fact that i don't
want to in any way contribute to
jk rowling's either wealth or popular
culture footprint
but the fact that i don't have a raid
capable of running current games and i
just kind of don't care that much
anyways hogwarts legacy
some interesting things have sort of
happened
and come out enough that the wheels have
gotten
rolling in my head again and well
here we are so if you are not
up to speed there is currently in the
works a
triple-a harry potter game called
hogwarts
legacy which is being developed by a
company called avalanche and is going to
be
released by warner brothers interactive
warner brothers is a fairly large name
in the gaming industry
they hold the arkham batman games they
hold
mortal kombat they hold the shadow uh
of mordor uh franchise now shadow of war
was their
their sequel so like they're not
tiny players they they're pretty big and
they
seem to be putting a heck of a lot more
effort into this than really
any previous harry potter related video
game
items i mean the video games that were
coming out in conjunction with the
movies were just shovelware for all
intents and purposes and then there was
the mobile game a few years back which
was
so just insidious in the way it was
built
to try and coax people to spend money on
it
especially given that it was aimed at
kids it was actually
really gross when that thing was and
that's like totally
separate from the person who that
license is benefiting just as a
product in and of itself that thing was
gross which is another reason i wouldn't
purchase this i don't trust warner
brothers
i don't trust them not to make an
absolute disaster
micro transaction nightmare out of the
thing
but anyway slightly off topic
so this game has been in development
actually since 2018 although it didn't
get announced until this past
fall which uh
you can yeah you have to feel at least a
little bit bad for the people involved
in making this because they've been
working on this for some time already
by the time jk rowling published her
essay which as a reminder was i believe
july of last year so
their game though would not get
announced for several months later was
already in development for some time
so that brings us to the more recent
stuff that's gone on
there was a leak of information that
went through
a journalist named jason schreier if you
know
games about our articles about the video
game
industry and some of its uh
let's go with uh less palatable
practices then you probably know his
name
and he revealed that the way the player
creation
character creation is being set up is in
such a way to allow
for basically doing some gender bending
on your character creation
this is a game where you create a custom
character to play through the story
so basically what they did was unbind
certain gendered characteristics so
you have the ability to select whether
your character is going to be a witch or
wizard
but for instance that doesn't lock you
into only specific
for example voice acting and you could
choose to be a witch with a masculine
voice or a wizard with a feminine voice
and those sorts of basically removing
restrictions
because usually on character creations
once you decide a certain body type it
limits a whole bunch of other options
that you're allowed to have
you know body type or gender um in this
case they're
unbinding some of those so that you can
mix and match and actually create
something that is
more akin to a trans person or a
um gender fluid sort of gender bendy
person there is really a
proper non-binary option but definitely
a lot more wiggle room
to mess around with that and create
something that
for a trans player may help them
approximate themselves
better than if those options were as
restricted as they usually
historically have been in these kinds of
games
now there's a couple of things that i
find interesting about this
and the first is if i can be completely
honest
this is and should be the bare minimum
level
of inclusion for trans people in games
i'm not saying this has no meaning or no
value
but this is literally the least they
could do
because there's no character in the game
no
scripted character who is trans
so far as we are aware and there's no
indication that that would be the case
i can't imagine they would hide that and
leak this other part as far as the
leaking i'll come back to that
but just removing restrictions
and allowing a character creator
the freedom to make something that is
not
a binary male or female character
that honestly should go without saying
if there is a character creation option
and i'm not just saying like
if you can choose a character some
things will have very clearly scripted
characters you can choose this one or
this one
not uncommonly male or female i'm not
even talking about that i'm talking
about if you're giving us a character
creator
if you're saying here make the character
how you want
then the least that you could do
[Music]
is unbind these options so that we can
truly make whoever we want
with whatever mix of gendered
characteristics we
wish them to have again
not without value not worthless but the
literal bare minimum
there actually is very little effort
to do this it's actually more effort
to prevent this because you have to put
those restrictions
in place in terms of locking out certain
voice or body type body type options
once someone chooses male or female
instead of just allowing them access to
everything
but there's a couple of things that i
want to talk about with the leaking of
this
the timing of it is kind of interesting
because the association with jk rowling
and the publication
of her transphobic views that is not up
for debate
if you tell me in the comments that you
don't think she's transphobic because
she says she
likes trans people i am going to block
you off being able to comment on my
channel in the future
do you also believe people who say i'm
not racist but
and then proceed to say something
horribly racist are you really gonna
take the word
of the person who's being accused of
transphobia that they're not transphobic
over the
over the voices of trans people who are
saying yes you
freaking are anyway so
even following on from that they've had
more recent issues because
the lead designer a gentleman by the
name of troy levitt
some old youtube videos from him have
resurfaced is sort of the best way that
i can think to say it
because they are videos in which he
amongst other things backs
gamergate and complains about sjw
wokeness which
is concerning and it's particularly
concerning in regards to
fans of the harry potter franchise
because part of the reason the whole
issue with jk rowling has been
such a problem for this fandom is by and
large
demographically speaking this fandom
is liberal leaning and
tends to be more supportive of lgbtq
plus people
in terms of broad demographics like if
somebody who was
well known to have more conservative
views came out as
transphobic that probably wouldn't cause
a massive
issue within the fandom of that creator
because
even if it wasn't assumed that that
person was transphobic it certainly
wasn't assumed that they would have been
an ally
there was an assumption of allyship from
jk rowling which ultimately turned out
to be a very false assumption and that's
sort of where the sense of betrayal came
in with her
so this is an audience
and a demographic and a fan base and i
brought this up when i talked about
amber heard
uh because i compared the fact that she
is at present
still on aquaman 2 to the releasing of
johnny depp from fantastic beasts 3.
the fan base for harry potter
is going to care more
about this kind of issue just again
demographically speaking and it's
possible
that troy levitt's views especially as
someone who spoke out in favor of
gamergate
and what a misogynistic hate mob
that was when you've got a fandom
with this high percentage of female fans
that's an
issue that's a problem now this is not
me saying that he should be fired this
is not me saying he should be canceled
there's no indication that that's going
to happen but
that ends up being one more pr issue now
to be fair the videos that are up are
around about three years old
and there don't seem to be a lot of
public statements from him at least that
have been found as yet
where he reinforces that these things he
still believes
that being said the fact that they were
never taken
down to me feels like an indication that
he has not had a
serious change of heart um it may
indicate a
softening or at least a desire to no
longer speak publicly about those things
but
i would have a hard time giving the
benefit of the doubt that
maybe his views are now significantly
changed if he just left those videos up
to be seen and found and be
representative
of him so so anyway as i said the timing
felt suspicious because there was the
already loaded issue of just the harry
potter name
and its association with jk rowling
which warner brothers has been trying to
distance itself
from in numerous ways i'll also come
back to that
but you've got that initially and then
troy levitt
doesn't help and then about a week
after stuff with him was started
hitting headlines the leak about
the ability to create trans characters
in the character creator comes out
i was honestly suspicious of it it
felt like a pr move and part of me
really did think i even tweeted about it
at the time
that this felt like damage control
this felt like the kind of decision that
would have been made from somebody who
knew that the thing was in the game
was looking at the bad press realized
that this
might conceivably help but that it would
look bad if it was a formal press
release because then it would be clear
that it was just being put out into the
public
sphere because they needed it for damage
control
i'm less inclined to think that now even
though i did initially
uh for a couple also let me be clear at
no point
even when i was being slightly
conspiratorial about it at no point did
i believe that it was
put into the game as a as a pr measure
it's in the game because the people
making the game or at least certain
elements of the game
wanted it there i think i had just been
suspicious that it the leak of the
information
about it might have been more targeted
and with more intent the thing is though
if they were going to leak it
they wouldn't do it through jason
schreyer
because triple a
video game publishers hate
jason schreier because he is one of the
people most consistent
consistently and vehemently writing
about their abuses
when it comes to the work environments
and things like crunch
and hostile workplaces and
some really nasty practices they
hate him if they wanted to leak this
they would not have leaked this
through him and i'm not conspiratorial
enough to go down the path of
ooh maybe that's why he's the perfect
cover he doesn't even know he's being
used i'm like he's been writing about
this for too dang long
he knows how to vet a source i think he
would have sniffed that
if they tried it i think they knew he
would have sniffed that if they were
going to try it which is why at this
point
i don't think it was a deliberate pr
move
that being said while it may not have
been a pr move
from the people at the top
i do find myself wondering about the
motivations for the leak at all and the
timing of the leak
from whatever anonymous individuals
leaked the information
and i have no reason to doubt the
information and
i also find it interesting to start to
think about
how many people on the team actually
would have
known this because as i said
there's almost nothing that would have
to be built
for this to be an option as i said
there's no flat out non-binary option if
there was and like say
they them pronouns were an option that
would have been
so many people would have had to know
because they would have had to have
voice actors record that the writers
would have known
the people lining up the the voice stuff
in the code with the models like they
would have
everybody would have known but
whoever is working on the character
builder
honestly they could have done this
completely on their own
without approval it's actually not
uncommon in video game development
because you have so many
either individuals or small teams
working in isolation on specific parts
it's not uncommon if they have the time
and aren't under crunch
for them to basically kind of fiddle
with something and make what they think
is cool and
then when it eventually gets reviewed
they'll get to find out whether
they get to keep it or not so that
possibility did enter my head that this
might not even have been something
signed off
from people like troy levitt or the
people at the top
this might have just been something that
the character creation team or even
certain individuals within the character
creation team might have decided on
their own
we can do this with the existing assets
we do not need to build anything new for
this we just have to fiddle with code
and unbind a few things
and then part of me wonders if
a reason to leak it
is so that once the public knows
it won't get cut because
if it's leaked and then the game comes
out
next year and that's not the case
well now warner brothers has to answer
to the fact that
there were more options in the character
creation
and they removed it once it's out in the
public
they kind of have to keep it because
removing it
and having that if if they had been able
to mandate hey
that thing you did in there cut no no
cut that and it
had all remained internal
well nobody would have ever known so
it's not
it's it becomes a non-issue it's a
strictly internal issue
whereas if that feature leaks
then the game comes out and the
feature's not there oh
somebody said to cut that
and then that uh that becomes a very
loaded very political
act to do and it's very clear that
warner brothers is trying
so hard to distance themselves from the
politics of jk rowling
when the game was first announced and as
i said it was announced after jk rowling
wrote her
essay in july they they
put out stuff you know official press
release stuff
distancing themselves not only from her
political views
but from her completely basically saying
she is not directly involved in this
game
in any way shape or form so it's very
clear that they are aware
of the problems around jk rowling right
now
especially with how divided her fan base
is however
this is where i have to circle back to
what has become the recurring
subject of this channel lately
which is separating the artist from the
art
what warner brothers wants and what
honestly the developers as well
want us to get in our heads
is that this is not jk rowling's game
they want a disassociation from her
they don't want us to think about her
when we
buy it but even if she is not
creatively involved
any purchase of this is still
going to benefit her
not only financially and we can't know
the details of that
because well they generally aren't
disclosed it's possible she was paid
a lump sum for the creation of the thing
it's possible she'll get a royalty on a
purchase basis but even if she wasn't
gonna make a
cent even if there was a deal in place
where she didn't make a
penny off the sale which is absolutely
not the case there's zero
zero chance that's the case but
hypothetically even if that was the case
i would still never pay money for this
because the reality in the situation
specific to jk rowling
and i will reemphasize these situations
are always case by case
but with jk rowling specifically
anything that bolsters
the profile of harry potter
as a property
benefits her because it keeps
her having a public platform
voice and influence and it is that
platform voice and influence that she
has decided to wield
against trans people i thought about
wearing some of my slithering gear for
this
and i'm not doing it i'm wearing one
item
which actually might not even be showing
up properly on the camera
but this which i might even have tilted
wrong way but this is the deathly
hallows
redone as a trans symbol
and i wore this because i think
specifically it would piss her off not
that she knows who i am
but i won't put on my actual slytherin
gear not even the unofficial stuff
because it bolsters the profile of the
property
and that bolsters the influence
that she is wielding against people like
me and as much as warner brothers
and the individual developers want to
distance themselves from that
they can't
they cannot remove that
from the equation and i feel really bad
for these developers
it's very clear that some of them who
knows how many
but some of them have serious issues and
a lot of discomfort about her views
and i'm not going to judge them for
continuing to work on this
they got this job before her views were
clearly known
and irrefutable but the ground level
developers also
aren't going to make residuals their
names are not going to be bolstered or
lowered
by the success or failure of this game
the only names that will get a boost on
whether or not this game is purchased
and successful
are the franchise name of harry potter
and jk rowling her name is inextricably
tied to harry potter
legally financially and by influence
so for as many other people are as
involved in the franchise at this point
all the actors at this point video game
developers
no matter how they feel about who she is
and what she is doing
their work contributes to her ability to
keep doing it
and again that's not necessarily a
judgment call on those individuals
that's just the reality i'm not going to
judge the people who choose to buy and
play this game
i'm not i only ask that you not
do the cliche of saying well she wasn't
involved separate the artist from the
art it doesn't matter no it does
it does it matters
everything that bolsters the profile of
harry potter
bolsters her ability to keep hurting
people
which is something she's actively doing
every time she speaks out about trans
issues
and at this point it is immensely clear
that she is not going to stop
doing that so while
i have utter sympathy for the developers
who did this and however far up the
chain that goes
maybe someone like troy levitt did know
and did sign off of it in which case
good for him i have sympathy
i appreciate the work that you're doing
but you can't remove her from this
property
as long as she continues to speak about
trans issues
as long as she uses the fame
and the fact that she is the harry
potter creator
as a way to bolster a harmful
and hurtful voice far louder than it
should ever
be bolstered then supporting that
franchise
empowers her ability to do that these
things are
are messy and i get that the
developers want to be judged on their
work and i
trust that many people will judge just
their work
and not delve into this
association beyond maybe a footnote
in a review but many won't even do that
because that'll be seen as bringing
politics in it
but because the influence of harry
potter
is what empowers jk rowling to do what
she's doing
you can't extricate the politics of that
from
a product that financially
and influentially benefits her
which sucks that is the concluding note
i almost always end on with these kinds
of videos
this all just
sucks and i feel bad for anyone who's
wrapped up in it
either because of their job and what
they're working on like with these
developers
or fans who are in emotional
turmoil every time this stuff comes back
around
it sucks for everybody but as much as i
take issue with the argument of separate
the artists from the art from a purely
philosophical
standpoint i will absolutely draw a line
in the sand when it comes to jk rowling
in particular
because it's not about something she did
is about something she
is now and continues to actively be
doing so it's not just a question of
whether or not it shows your support for
her beliefs
even if you believe the absolute
opposite of her
anything you do that bolsters her
influence or her finances
empowers her to keep doing what she's
doing
because it is an ongoing thing at this
point it's not a one-off
it's not an incident it's not a thing
that happened
it's a thing that is still happening and
will continue
to happen for as long as she's capable
of doing it
which [ __ ] sucks
so hogwarts legacy and the ability to
sort of gender
blend your player character
and ultimately uh a ramble about
this particular franchise is tied to its
creator and again
i do want to stress this is kind of
specific to harry potter and jk rowling
because this is an ongoing thing
this is something she continues to do so
unlike other situations like say joss
whedon
gina carano johnny depp amber heard
innumerable others where it's a question
of are we going to punish them for
something they
did and that is a debate to be had
that's not even the question with
anything tied to harry potter and jk
rowling
the question here is are we going to
keep empowering her to continue to do it
people will make their own calls on that
whatever your thoughts are in regards to
this
as long as it isn't trying to argue with
me and try and tell me that jk rowling
is not in fact transphobic
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
i have a patreon if you like what i do
this is in fact my living
it is how i pay my bills it's also my
birthday this month so that'd be a nice
present
um but you don't have to
like share subscribe they help me out as
well
and they would be greatly appreciated
but you don't
have to do any of it at the end of the
day you are the council
and i'm only running the meetings until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]